foreign
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
oh yes yes yes yes love you so much
I'm lying
happy July 10th everyone so as the rest
of the country kicked off the summer
with cookouts and fireworks and blackout
drinking
the usual Progressive killjoy spoke up
to remind us of what a terrible Place
America really is
it's like expecting Betsy Ross's flag
and ending up with Jane Fonda's dirty
girdle
dirty girdle
I don't know what that means Ben and
Jerry's ice cream part of an enormous
multinational European Corporation
offered their happy birthday message to
Americans last week by proclaiming that
the country with stolen land and should
be given back to indigenous peoples the
company advises to start with Mount
Rushmore a lousy idea since there's no
way a mountain can sustain a casino
but then something awesome happened
turns out Ben and Jerry's headquarters
are located on land which the Abenaki
Native American nation says belongs to
them
yeah I'm taste I'm tasting a new flavor
of ice creams and it's hypocrite and
honey
in fact Abenaki Chief Don Stevens that's
the Abenaki Chief Don Stevens the Don
Stevens told Newsweek he'd be interested
in a meeting with the company to discuss
the land being returned and you don't
get more Native American than you know
Don Stevens right wasn't he the husband
from Bewitched I don't know that was Dan
I don't know Dean who cares no heckling
but Don Steven sounds like the name Bill
Hammer gives when he stays at the Red
Roof Inn out by the airport
I'm sorry I just prefer my indigenous
people to have more traditional names
like Chief Running Bear or Liz Warren
but
in the ice cream Maker's defense you
could say everywhere in America or in
the world in fact once belonged to
someone else my apartment is actually
over an old burial ground I know this
because I did the bearing
in fact even the Indian tribe that wants
Mount Rushmore back the Lakota
apparently took it from other Indian
tribes so if you're sincere Ben and
Jerry's then you should start with your
own HQ I'm sure there are plenty of
Native Americans more than willing to
dispossess you of your no doubt multiple
homes and since you live in Vermont you
could give away all your homes and still
rent one from Bernie Sanders
well you came up with those 98 flavors
on Stolen land and not one of them named
after a tribe or a chief there's no
reservation Ripple
smoke signal sorbet
Peace by pistachio
big cover-up that's what it is and as
others have pointed out you made your
ice cream from the milk of cows who
never consented right yeah we had the me
too movement maybe it's time for a moo
too movement
but here's the good news and I'm sure
you won't get grossed out by this the
Centers for Disease Control just issued
guidelines for how biological men can
chest feed children meaning men who
identify as women can now take drugs so
they can breastfeed like women which
means B and J if you're truly
Progressive stop taking milk from cows
who can't consent and get the milk from
biological men with boobs who can
came from here
came from in here somewhere and you can
call the new flavor Dylan Mulvaney munch
just don't ask what the crunchy bits are
they identify as toffee I'll be in
there
you see as someone smart once said
idealism exists in direct proportion to
one's distance from the problem from a
mountain in Vermont giving away Mount
Rushmore must make a person feel pretty
righteous but no matter how much they
virtue signal Ben and Jerry's they're
not going to give up their stolen land
because as soon as progressives face the
realities of their virtue signaling they
disappear like an investigation into
West Wing cocaine
remember the migrants DeSantis flew into
Martha's Vineyard 50 among the millions
who had entered the country illegally
caused the biggest Panic that Island
seen since the great arugula shortage of
2013.
they were welcomed like a shark with
genital warts
New York's Long Island the Shinnecock
Indian nation has been asking for the
Hamptons back for years the celebrities
say no thanks but Don Lemon said tell me
more about this Shinnecock
who's interested in other cultures
that contain
silicon-based life form Mark
Zuckerberg's donated Millions to
anti-cop groups all while spending 43
million on his own security so he
doesn't want to defund all police just
your police I hope Elon Musk roundhouse
kicks his head right out of the octagon
but it's all the same screaming right
support for things you exempt yourself
from thanks to wealth and power so Ben
and Jerry's we're not giving back Mount
Rushmore and after the Fallout caused by
you crapping on the 4th of July you
might want to contemplate a new flavor
chunky chapter 11. you can make can make
it with Bud Light and sell it
exclusively at Target
let's welcome
tonight's guests
he was the inspiration for getting a
second opinion hosts have asked Dr Drew
Dr Drew Pinsky
no he's so for giving back meaning
refunds to disappointed fans actor
writer comedian and divorce dad Jamie
LaSalle
she's petite upbeat and will throw up in
your back seat boxes contributor katip
and big Ben is his pocket watch my
massive Sidekick is at the nwa's World
Heavyweight Champion Towers
Jamie uh does this controversy matter to
you in a big way
it doesn't but how great was it when we
found out that uh Ben and Jerry's was on
that land it was a wonderful wonderful
thing I read an article that said almost
everyone eats Ben and Jerry's when
they're depressed that's why you eat
Benadryl that's why I always keep one
handy for after I sleep with a girl
um I mean I'll give it to her when I
sleep with a girl
um
yeah isn't the Mount Rushmore thing like
you can have Mount Rushmore isn't it
probably because it it sucks well you
build you believe it's overrated don't
you I believe it's over like we wouldn't
give away like the Grand Canyon do you
know 2.4 million people regret driving
to Mount Rushmore each year really it's
one of the seven wonder why I went
there's of the world
where is it by the way is it in Wyoming
I Googled the Dakotas this is Black
Hills I swear I go no need to get racist
I really did I Googled where is Mount
right Google is like I don't I'm not
even sure yeah um but can I say one
thing about chest feeding sure I just
you know the real controversy is I think
that there could be chemicals in the
breast milk because the progressor being
augmented chemically which I think
there's a solution to this like if you
just talk to like I would say at least
half the guys from my high school have
naturally bigger breasts than they had
um when I went yes I know how they grew
those yes that's true you work out and
then they just go to pot you know what
I'm saying speaking of going to pop weed
can cause some breast growth too that is
true gynecomastia gynecomastia thank you
very much as opposed to galactorrhea
which is what we're talking about here
today yeah well here's the deal yeah
here's you you got two ways to go with
this I got two questions because you're
a doctor or you claim to be one yeah
I've never had to remove my clothing in
front of you but a even though you've
tried yes I've tried Ben and Jerry's Ben
and Jerry's responsible for killing more
people than probably anything on the
planet through obesity related diseases
B what's up with this chest feeding
this is
mental illness well I you know just from
a medical standpoint in order to get the
pituitary gland to secrete all that
prolactin to cause men to produce milk
that is really dangerous I mean these
are serious medication and I was I
looked up a couple of them today and
they are not allowed during for
breastfeeding women yes you're not
allowed to expose a breast when a woman
to these medications it's insane we're
we're breaking the rules for the tiniest
minority of people who are mentally ill
it's insane it's the insane part is for
me two things the the medications that
are being used are very serious and we
don't know the long-term effects of them
even to this day and two you know for
some people the doctors are making the
right choice to do this but some people
are not happy with the choice and
getting the right patient for the right
treatment is our job and if we screw
that up that's on us I knew I should
have become a doctor I would have been
so good at it but I didn't want to go to
med school well you have to so I was
thinking you don't like people I don't
like people I would have the highest
mortality rate
your best day would be telling people
they're done exactly didn't come in with
like a clown nose on good news nope
you're dying I would be the happiest
Angel of Death yes
you told me you were a doctor
Poetic Justice cat poetic justice for
Ben and Jerry's huh well maybe I see I'm
not a lawyer but there's not a law
against them giving away their land they
have right no no law they can just feel
free to do that yes Jamie gave away his
house
well that wasn't illegal she wasn't even
a Native American no I mean
I guess I'm better than they are yeah
because I don't
know that's right I rent on some yeah
that's true and you might you might not
know this but you might rent from a
Native American that makes you like
almost like doing charity work
I like to think every day is charity
work yeah I think so too although I
think okay so for the chess feeding
thing I just want to say I did also read
that stuff about the chemicals being bad
for men or for people I was disappointed
because I don't want to do it you want
cam to do it yeah that could be another
thing that I could Pawn off onto my
husband I'd be all for it
I don't want that image needs to go away
well husbands do it all the time it's
called a bottle so
the problem that I have with it is in no
way it's for the benefit of the child
yeah so when a man wants a child to be
on his chest I just think pedophile I
think disgusting why would you want to
do that it's not for the better of the
child it's for you how is it not
pedophilia it is
chest and you take drugs for
look I mean there's just no reason for
that yeah it's great the only thing that
makes me feel good about this monologue
is all is that the fact that the new Ben
and Jerry says they've made a bed and
now they have to give it away so I love
it like they should one thousand percent
have to give their land away put your
money with this is what happens a virtue
signal it's all fun again when it's
virtual reality then reality showed up
and they're like well uh what what tribe
did you say
amanaki oh they were the racist one so
they're not getting anything they made
deals with uh General custard so they
can they'll find some loophole to
justify because really their stuff
should be out by now they should be
rolling the freezers out and the flavors
and all that stuff shouldn't take that
long to transfer power that's the
Indians reparations ice cream in their
building but they have something you
want to show us oh yeah I'm sorry the
whole man feeding thing just doing the
mood but here's something positive it's
a it's a little promo of our upcoming
time change yes
how will the show be different in our
new time slot
it won't be
same old crap just an hour earlier
Gutfeld malwarering one hour earlier
beginning July 17th
catching me on my way to the gym you're
never gonna get a happy Tyrus you got to
catch me after this but that's true I
don't think but we're still going to do
promos right nothing's going to change I
mean we're not gonna have Jamie on
anymore but we're gonna do we're you
know because
uh did I say that out loud and part of
the deal with Ben and Jerry's was they
also wanted you so oh yeah
but but that aphorism you put up there
was so apt you know the distance from
the reality of your opinions you know
like Look at California we were locked
down had to wear masks our governor goes
to the French Laundry with one of his
friends people that are that are leading
the way on uh climate change or running
around the world in a private jet yeah
this is hypocrisy at the highest level
and the lowest level I never know what's
better is it at the highest level or the
lowest level we must move on but right
should they pick the lowest level yes
thank you yeah I don't know when they go
like uh oh he's going downhill I'm like
oh is that good or bad well he's the
worst liar ever that makes him honest
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else